These beautiful stitch
patterns have so many uses.
You often see them in the hand knitting
world, but as machine knitters, they're
completely do-able.
I call these center double decreases, but
keep in mind, no stitches are actually
decreased.
The number of stitches
in work remain the same.
We're just doing some hand manipulation
to create texture and interest.
Here's an example of a
center double decrease.
The handling instructions
might call this a PSSO.
The instructions might read, slip one,
knit two together, pass the slip, stitch.
Over the hand knitting
chart would look like this.
Notice that direction at
the front stitches laying.
On the machine, to create this design, we
need to shuffle three stitches around so
that front stitch is in front.
For this example, I've identified these
needles as the center of my double
decreases.
Start by moving the marked needle to
the left, doubling up two stitches.
Then moved these two stitches
back to that marked center needle.
Next, transfer the right
stitch over those two stitches.
So you've got three stitches on the
center needle and two emptied needles.
Now I'll repeat this across the
row, working on my marked needles.
All this shuffling around, put a single
stitch leaning left on the front side of
the knitting.
Notice that there's still
two emptied needles.
To complete the design, I'll use a three
prong tool to transfer three stitches to
fill in those newly emptied needles.
Now you could move any number of stitches
I just chose three for, because I have a
three-prong transfer tool.
This creates eyelets away from the
decrease, and that's what creates our
design.
I've set up my stitch pattern to have
a single stitch bordered by eyelets on
either side of that double decrease.
Get creative and do whatever you'd like.
We just need to account for those eyelets
and position them in a decorative manner.
After you work this stitch pattern for a
few rows, notice how the stitches seem to
move at a diagonal.
This is what I think makes this a
really interesting stitch pattern.
One more time.
You've identified your center stitch,
you're going to transfer that center
stitch to the left, transfer the two
stitches back to the center, transfer the
single right stitch over to the center.
Making sure you have three
stitches on that center needle.
Fill in the empty needles,
knit two rows and repeat.
Now that you've seen all those stitch
transfers, could you do this with a lace
carriage?
Of course!
The challenge would be to punch a card or
program your machine for multiple stitch
transfers.
And make sure they all go
in the right direction.
Now another option for this would be to
have the decrease leaning to the right.
In hand knitting,
this would be knit three together.
For machine knitters, we would just
transfer the stitches in the opposite
direction.
Here's another popular option.
Manipulate those stitches so
the center stitch is in front.
When you're looking at the work from the
knit side, and that center stitch creates
a column.
I'm using needle number five as my center.
I'll transfer one stitch right.
And one stitch left ending up with three
stitches on that center needle again, but
this time they're in a different sequence
and that center stitch is going to be in
front when you look at
it from the right side.
I'll then fill in the empty needles, just
like before having eyelets away from that
center stitch.
Here's my column of stitches.
And the diagonal appearance on each side.
This is just one little taste of
what you can do with this technique.
I suggest you draw it out first.
Use the little stitch symbols to indicate
which direction you're moving stitches.
I challenge you to play with stitch
transfers and make your own design.
Happy knitting!